[Music]
do you know what a beam is there are
many different meanings of this word in
physics we use this word in two ways in
optics we say a beam of light it can be
thought of as a sequence of photons
traveling in a straight line in
mechanical engineering a beam is a long
piece made of some material it can be a
wooden beam a steel beam or a concrete
beam we are of course interested in this
kind of beam let's draw a rough general
sketch of a rectangular beam okay say we
apply a downward force F on the surface
area of a beam here the force is trying
to compress the beam from the top due to
this the beam will experience some
stress it is just an uncomfortable State
experienced by the object which is the
beam in this case the atoms inside are
little too close than they want to be
this results in inter atomic and
intermolecular forces and if the applied
force F is within the elastic limits of
the material these forces bring back the
object to its initial State when the
applied force is removed mathematically
stress is defined as force per unit
cross sectional area so it is F over a
where a is this cross-sectional area
what if I increase the force from F
Newton to say F Plus 10 Newton on this
area a intuitively we know that if we
push it with a greater force from above
then the beam will experience more
stress mathematically this new stress
will be F plus 10 over a the numerator
increased and the denominator remained
the same it means that this ratio is
greater than this one so if we increase
the force the stress will also increase
next what will happen if I increase the
surface area from a meter squared to say
a plus 10 meter squared
will the stress increase in this case
too the stress will decrease in this
case because the denominator increases
with the numerator remaining constant
now what is the SI unit of stress any
guesses stress is force per unit area
the SI unit of force is Newton denoted
by n and that of area is meter squared
so the SI unit of stress is Newton per
meter squared
however this unit is given a name and
it's called baska denoted by PA now we
know the basics about stress
what is strain in very simple language
one can define it as change in
dimensions per unit of original
dimensions when any object is under
stress it will change one or more of its
dimensions the amount by which the
object's dimensions will change will
depend on the force applied and the
materials the object is made up of in
our example L is the length of the beam
and it's experiencing some force hence
it will deform and its length will
change by say Delta L strain is defined
as change in length per unit of the
original length mathematically it is
Delta L over L so what does this ratio
do well the ratio compares the change in
length that resulted due to force with
the original length of the beam here
strain is calculated in terms of length
of the object but the length may not be
the only quantity changing due to
deformation we can also find the strain
in terms of area and volume let's take
an example of a sponge ball of volume V
when it's compressed its volume
decreases so the strain in terms of
volume is Delta V over V note that Delta
V is the change in volume and not the
volume of the deformed sphere let's take
another example where a thin rubber
sheet is stretched equally from the
opposite sides with a force
and that will result in a change in the
area so the strain experienced by the
rubber sheet is Delta a over a Delta a
is the change in area of the sheet and a
is the original area of the sheet so in
the next video we will see the types of
stress and strain see you there
[Music]
you